-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
I'm Steve Higgins, and we are
about to play "Pup Quiz."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Aww! Playing tonight,
we have the host of "The
Tonight Show," Mr. Jimmy Fallon.
-Oh, hi, everybody. Hello.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And his opponent, the writer
of the "Comedians in Cars
Getting Coffee Book" available
now, Mr. Jerry Seinfeld.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this is the first puppy
up for grabs.
Gary Frick Jr.
[ Audience aws ]
Here's how the game works.
I'll be asking both of you
animal trivia questions.
And if you answer correctly,
you win a Labrador
Retriever puppy.
-It's a great game.
-If you answer incorrectly,
your opponent gets the puppy.
So whoever has
the most puppies
at the end of the game
is guess what.
The Pup Quiz champion. Jerry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jerry, you're our guest.
So you'll answer
the first question.
-Who is Gary Frick Jr.?
-Him right here.
-Gary Frick Jr. is
the name of the dog.
And originally,
my dog's name was Gary.
-Oh.
-That was the first
Gary Frick Jr.
-Yeah, and it was a puppy
from this show.
And it was a sketch we did.
And then at the end of the show,
I surprised my wife
with the puppy.
-Oh, my God.
[ Audience aws ]
-Never surprise
your wife with a puppy.
[ Laughter ]
Terrible, terrible thing.
-Really?
-It's like getting someone
a job.
[ Laughter ]
Honey, surprise.
You now work at 7-Eleven.
[ Laughter ]
-You're the assistant manager.
-That's great.
Don't cut that out.
Leave that joke in.
That's great.
[ Laughter ]
-I love that. Jerry Seinfeld's
like, "I loved it."
It makes my whole year.
Made my whole year.
Alright, here we go.
-Alright, Jerry,
here's your question.
Where do wild turkeys sleep?
Is it A, in trees?
B, in tall grass?
Or C, in mud?
-Or D, who cares?
[ Laughter ]
The answer would be B,
in tall grass.
-This one's obvious.
-Tall grass.
That's what you're going to say?
-Yes.
-Ooh! You're wrong.
[ Buzzer ]
The correct answer is trees.
So, Jimmy,
you get Gary Frick Jr.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, buddy.
-There you go.
Trees.
-Hi.
-Next question is for you,
Jimmy.
Again, another turkey question.
Turkeys have three times
better blank than humans.
Smell, vision, or hearing?
-Well, they got to listen for,
like, knives sharpening.
-I'm going to say they have
better hearing than humans.
-Is that your final answer?
-Yes.
[ Buzzer ]
-That is incorrect. It's vision.
-I get a puppy!
-Jerry gets the next puppy.
Adorable Mary Kennedy.
-Oh, there you go.
-Hi. Hello.
-Does it make you happy?
-Yeah.
-Mary Kennedy.
-I got you. I got you.
-A puppy that makes you happy.
[ Barking ]
-Oh!
You know what that sound means.
-That means...
-Time for Double Puppardy.
[ Laughter ]
Where the questions are now
worth two puppies.
-Oh!
-So it gets real spicy.
Okay, Jerry, next question
for you.
Group of turkeys
is called a what?
An A bale, B, parliament,
or C, rafter?
-This is supposed
to be a fun show.
[ Laughter ]
These are like brain-breaking
questions.
-You're sitting in a La-Z-Boy
with a puppy.
This is -- How more fun can you
get? I mean, come on.
[ Laughter ]
-A rafter.
-Is that your final answer?
Correct!
-Wow. Look at you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Your new puppies are
Kyle McAdams and Lisa Armstrong.
Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, I am puppy rich.
Puppy rich. Puppies, puppy.
-Okay, Next question
goes to Jimmy.
-Feeling a little lonely
over there?
[ Laughter ]
-We're bonding. We're bonding.
-Male turkey droppings, right?
You know what that is.
Have a distinct shape
that looks like what?
A, a teardrop.
-Oh, gosh.
-B, an infinity sign.
-We just ate.
[ Laughter ]
-Or C, the letter J.
-That would be rude, right?
[ Laughter ]
-The infinity sign
is just stupid.
-That is just absolutely ridic--
-That takes a lot of effort.
-But if I did see that,
I would be kind of amazed.
That would go on my Instagram,
probably.
-Yeah.
-Like a lowercase J can I ask?
[ Laughter ]
-You said does it have
a little dot on the top?
That I don't know.
-I'm going to say --
I don't know.
Turkey droppings. Teardrop.
-Teardrop? No!
[ Buzzer ]
The correct answer
was the letter J.
-Yeah, letter J.
-Jerry, say hello to
Roger Blaine and Ted Mooney.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh.
-This is insane. This is insane.
Everyone's sniffing
each other's crotch.
No one cares about anything.
The rules have gone off.
This is off the rails.
-Oh!
-[ Barking ]
Wow.
You know what that sound means.
-What?
-Time for Final Puppardy.
-Okay. There you go.
-This question is for all
your opponent's puppies
and the game.
-We have crushed him.
[ Audience aws ]
-Come on! Come on now.
-Guys, get focused. Get focused.
[ Laughter ]
-On average --
-Come on, Gary.
Let's figure it out, buddy.
-On average,
how many turkeys does Butterball
sell per year?
That's a toughie.
-On average?
-On average.
10 seconds starting now!
-10 seconds. A year.
-A year?
-Yeah.
-I couldn't even tell you a day.
-Who cares?
-A year?
-Uh, how many turkeys
are there altogether?
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
-Um, I'll say...
-This is -- If one of us
gets this right,
that would be insane.
I don't think we'd ever speak
to each other again.
-I got it.
-Oh, you got it?
Alright, Jimmy,
what did you write down?
-I wrote 200,000.
-Ooh!
A year? Really?
Okay, Jerry,
what did you write down?
-200,000.
-Wow!
-Dude!
-The answer...
...is 13 million!
You both win.
[ Dinging ]
-We both wrote 200,000 turkeys.
-That is bizarre.
We bonded forever.
200,000 turkey-- Jerry Seinfeld,
everybody.
All these adorable puppies.
Happy Thanksgiving.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Adam Devine, everybody.
Come on back.